père de l'une était militaire le père de
l'eau déserteurs voici les demi-soeurs
voici l'ex wanda alias lio dans le who's
who meaux et helena qui jouait ce
interviewait façon slc star by star
belle du soir dans lunettes noires et ta
soeur
voilà six ans rencontré dans son squat
et que c'était un mec
par exemple si on dirait que tu fais
quoi et que tu étouffes alors d'entrer
je te dis moi c'est la forme écrit et je
dis que j'attends avec impatience que
fellini
jim jarmusch m'offre un rôle et que les
seuils vainement qu'il maisons disent
que signe mon magnifique album
tu crois que ça fait de cette desserte
by coulter ça me serre et samedi ce
faire
et là dans le désert que c'est ce
n'était pas ma soeur est ce que tu
aurais envie de chanter
si tu étais bouchehr je serais venu
boscher le suspense on a quoi de
différent et quads pareil on n'a pas la
même taille le même tour de poitrine
qu'on a on n'a pas les mêmes pieds on a
presque le même tailleur est ce que tu
crois que ce serait différent si on
était sort soeur et pas demi soeur
non je pense pas alors quand maman
divorcée vous êtes parti à bruxelles
est ce que ça peut être rebaptisé
peut-être bien en tout cas c'est une
expérience marquante pour moi mais est
traumatisé je sais pas je ne sais pas
j'ai peut-être qu'un traumatisme
peut-être que tourne a traumatisé mais
je pense pas ça plus qu'autre chose peu
plus que ma première déception
sentimentale ou n'importe quoi c'est
juste un moment tu te souviens de ton
premier mec
et quoi premier mec quoi prenez un coup
d'oeil petit cran moyenne et toi tu t'en
souviens enfin je veux dire pas du mien
du tiens de mon premier mec mais comment
grandes ou petites
le choix d'aurélie dans un journal que
tu voulais être encore plus sexy que ma
soeur ah oui ça c'est dans confidences à
cesser de la foire est qui qui a si
c'est ça je ne sais pas et est plus sexy
que toi est ce que c'est encore possible
a dit lundi à l'ats n'ont même pas je ne
fais que je ne crois pas on veut pas
dire ne se remet dans un studio que tu
détestes en moi
quand tu es malheureux je crois
alors on fait comme à la télé et tu vas
me dire que tu as comme projet de disque
ou de films au fc sète enfin étape et
lunettes noires qu'est ce que tu as fait
j'ai glander galéré et un galéré
gentiment et julie frontignan comme
maman